the only way to get out of it is well
it's not the only way the best way or or
one of the key ways is is disseminate
what we stand for
which is why this Prager U which is why
I'm writing the rational Bible which is
why you do what you do
uh
that is why by the way they try to shut
us down they know we can undo why is it
a big deal if you go to a college campus
or I do or or Ben Shapiro or Jordan
Peterson or Candace Owens why did they
give a damn
they have four years to indoctrinate we
get a 90 minutes because they know in
their heart we can undo four years and
90 minutes
I'm Dave Rubin and joining me today is
the founder of prageru as well as the
author of the brand new book the
rational Bible Deuteronomy God blessings
and curses Dennis Prager welcome back to
the Reuben report
I love being with you great to be there
Dennis I am always happy to talk to you
my first question is you've written
according to my research uh
351 books this is your uh
2477th appearance on the Reuben report
which one of those would you say is a
higher Accolade for you
if they were to put one on my Tombstone
it will definitely be the Reuben report
appearances
when you wait I mean think about it you
weigh the Bible
and then the Dave Rubin report come on
come on how many books is this for you
for real I mean you there's got to be
you know what this is very interesting I
have no idea what this will say about me
positive negative or neither
I don't know how many books I've written
but I do know exactly how many countries
I have visited how many countries have
you visited
131 wow Slovakia was my 131st last year
what's uh what's remaining for you I
mean do you have anything that you okay
it's getting tough Rwanda I haven't been
to Rwanda haven't been to Mongolia I
mean the the you know I've been to 20
African countries but I think there were
40.
so you know you know I've been on my
mission to get you to move to Florida
but I see Rwanda is in your heart
that is very funny I I Rwanda was for a
visit
Florida hey by the way are you worried
about the hurricane
so as we're recording this right now you
know I'm in Miami so it looks like it it
hit the West Coast unbelievably hard
like category five uh my folks have a
place over there that we're just praying
isn't going to be destroyed uh but oh
God but to bring it to a little bit of
the politics and then we'll get into the
book I mean DeSantis is doing everything
possible but the media is just waiting
are you feeling that were you talking
about that on your radio show this
morning that the media is just waiting
for one disaster to really strike so
they can say this is the thing and he's
incompetent and he's evil and awful and
like they would love for Destruction
basically is what I'm saying
uh I want you to know that it is not
easy for me to say I agree with you in
this case
I think the left hatred
of us is so great
that a certain amount of joy
would be in their hearts they wouldn't
express it of course
if if Florida were hurt
and by the way I don't think it's
symmetrical
I loathe what the Democrats have done to
where I still live in California
it would bring me no joy if some natural
disaster hit California
I I don't think there's symmetry in in
the uh in the hatreds well well that
symmetry or that asymmetry as you put
that's sort of connected to what this
book is about because it's about God and
the Bible and goodness and things of
that nature and and you know that I'm
sort of you as I sort of call you my
you're my quote-unquote Rabbi and we're
actually taping this right in between
Rosh Hashanah and Yom Kippur so this is
an important week for the Jewish people
to reflect on life and all that stuff
and you've you've reconnected me with a
lot of these things
um that there's a reason for that
asymmetry I think that politics is their
world view while generally speaking more
conservative leaning people and I don't
mean that purely in a conservative sense
politically but conservative leaning
people have another ideology so it does
make sense right I would go further we
have another life it's so interesting
you should mention that
so I think you know but I'm sure most of
your viewers don't or listeners
I have been conducting the Jewish High
holy day Services as if I were a rabbi
I'm not I'm not ordained but as as so to
speak Arabi for 15 years this was the
15th year
about 400 people attend
oh you've attended actually I've I've
been many times actually the first time
I was there was about four years ago or
so you were giving the sermon and you
were discussing something about same-sex
couples and you referenced David and I
being at dinner at our house a few days
before you didn't even know I was there
I did not I mean we were there that's
right but I've been many times in its
standing room only and it's and it's
wonderful what you do ordained or not
yeah exactly so I want to comment on on
your point about the the different life
so first by the way I just want for
those interested they can watch my
service anytime they want till January
1st now or anytime at salemnow.com
just so they should know that and the
music is incredible by the way you get
people the music is incredibonic and all
sorts of stuff oh no no it's it's the
whole thing I explain everything
non-jews watch it even more than Jews do
because they're a lot more non-jews than
Jews but but it appeals to everybody
so anyway I actually
noted on my show when I returned from my
two-day break
how important it is in my life that I
have another life a life of religion
and when you when one doesn't have that
and everything everything is secular
there is a real Danger
that and this is the danger of the left
part of it everything is then politics
everything the purpose of your life the
meaning it's it's your interest it's
your passion
it's not my interest it's not my passion
my uh I I'm passionate about about the
ultimate questions of life which is why
I'm writing my Bible commentary because
if people understand the first five
books which are by far the most
important in all of the Bible
Jesus would have said that as as Jesus
uh and uh and as a Jew which he was the
most important books actually ever
written
and you will find this fascinating I
just learned this sadly after I'd
already completed Deuteronomy it's the
fifth book but it's my third I didn't go
in order
and you will find this fascinating as I
did
the founders of the country cited
Deuteronomy more than any other
religious or secular work
in in the in their writings and in their
speeches that's how much this book
influenced the creation of the freest
country ever made and and so that that
should be if if one needs one and I
think does one need one most people
never heard of Deuteronomy
but it is it is a phenomenal work of the
five books it's Moses's summary of
everything
this Israelites this humanity is what is
important I'll give you one example so I
wrote a column for Fox giving seven
great
insights and just from the book
do not show partiality and judgment
there is a specific law
in both Exodus and Deuteronomy you
cannot it's specific you'll love this
Dave you cannot favor the poor man who
comes into your court justice is Justice
it is like a law against social justice
there was only Justice it's basically
it's a law against Equity that's that's
sort of a talk exactly
equity and Liberty are mutually
exclusive
that's exactly right give me one more
that's in that column
okay so another one here so do not be
afraid of anyone
only fear God fear of God is the
antidote to fear of man I know it
because it's operative in my life I
don't give a damn about what the New
York Times writes about me it means
nothing I sleep perfectly fine that
night I don't walk around fearing anyone
and you don't know how liberating that
is that is why one of the three models
of the country is in In God We Trust
not we trust will take care of us it's
God who matters and of course man
matters obviously but not in terms of
fear you can't you you if you don't fear
God you will fear man humans fear it is
part of our makeup it is impossible not
to have fears
but you can liberate yourself from it if
you fear the right party which which is
God I'll give you let me just ask you
something on that before you continue
did you always have that within you I
mean you I think you've always had it as
you know for the now eight or so years
that I've known you and people know this
story but at the height of covid when I
dragged you out to a trump rally and you
literally said to me unvax you and unvax
me I hope I get coveted here and then of
course the media all called for you to
die and you eventually did get coveted
and you survived much to their Chagrin
but the point is you weren't being
dominated by fear was that always in you
or was that something you learned very
early yeah I I I I learned it I learned
it and imbibed it uh it became part of
my nature by the way I just want to make
clear it was it was partially
tongue-in-cheek about wanting covet what
I did want
was a way to get antibodies you said
that for sure and and you know I I'm not
an idiot obviously but I I I turned out
right I turned out right when I said
that the lockdowns were the greatest
International mistake in human history
and and and and and they were they were
devastating keeping kids out of school
for two years was a crime literally a
crime it was a crime against children I
you know look we both feel this way I
you know I don't know I don't have to
belabor the point but
uh the let's put it this way I wrote a
piece about 20 years ago how the left
keeps me religious you'd love it that
might explain my religious revival over
here
that yes of course it would
I have I have been honest enough to say
if the anti-religious left and the left
is anti-religious from from Lenin to to
Soros
if the left had produced
kind intelligent wise people
my religious beliefs would have been
challenged I fully acknowledge it
because I judge ideologies by their
product
and that's why I don't judge people's
theology or philosophy but the left
is is is wrong on everything ruins
everything and most of them aren't nice
I'm not talking liberals you know I make
a distinction Liberals are weak but
they're not bad
um you know it's interesting because as
you know we we just had Justin a couple
weeks ago and we've got number two baby
number two on the way but we did we did
the bris at eight days and you know it's
if you look at it from a purely secular
point of view it's it's somewhat of a
crazy thing to do you bring this perfect
thing into the world and then and then
you're cutting this child that's what
you're doing and I remember we David and
I had this talk before about you know
our our thoughts on everything and my
overriding feeling about it was that my
parents did it their parents did it
their parents parents did it and Way
Beyond that for something like
5783 years three thousand well really
thirty two hundred yes yeah that or four
thousand actually four thousand right
the calendar but we go back to Abraham
okay but the point is that it's been
done for a long long time and I felt
that that am I just wiser than everyone
that came before me oh God bless you oh
that's so the perfect reaction and
that's what they believe they think they
are let's believe they are the best
people who ever lived
they do that's why they tear down
Lincoln and Washington we are better
than them they don't hold a candle to
these people by the way I just want you
to know I I have two sons as you'll have
God willing and I had uh I don't cry
easily
and I was with the two times I most
remember sobbing
was at their brisk at their at their
circumcision exactly for what you said
holy crow
this goes back for a thousand years I'm
not prepared to end it it just felt
crazy to me like no I just know so much
I just know so much I won't do this
thing the people before me were so dumb
it's it's it's it's almost grotesque in
a in a bizarre sense to think that way
but do you think that that so you're
writing this book as all of this coveted
craziness is going down and you're
you're making this distinction between
you know politics and having a religious
worldview or just something that's not
politics and then you see the people in
the name of science uh sort of become I
wouldn't say religious they became
cult-like in their following of this
stuff that must have been interesting to
be writing this at the same time
okay
all it did is reinforce everything I was
writing and and everything do you know
that there's another law in the Torah
uh to give you an idea of how
contemporaneous this stuff is do not
follow the majority
to do bad
could have put that one on Twitter
Dennis is that mind-blowing
a Biblical law
do you think somehow that religious
people didn't sell this stuff well
enough like what what do you think
happened correct is that you're right
that you hit it Dave you're so in touch
with everything it cracks me up talking
to you is such a joy likewise that's
that's that is thank you that is exactly
correct
the religious are as responsible for the
rampant
non-religiosity as an anti-religious
armor that is exactly do you think that
goes across across religions from a
western sense oh completely Christians
failed to teach religion properly Jews
failed to teach religion properly they
all relied on
uh inertia
I'm religious my kid'll be religious end
of issue by the way Americans did it as
Americans Americans didn't sell America
to their kids
you you and that's another law in
Deuteronomy you have to teach these
things
diligently to your children when you
wake up when you go to bed when you walk
by the way the these are all it's so
brilliant you can't stop and it's
perfect to tell you because you're gonna
have you have one and a half or one and
three quarters
you got Dave you you guys gotta talk to
your kids about values constantly I
think I know I drove my kids crazy I had
one message I don't give a damn about
your grades
all I care about is your character have
a great day
and your kids are pretty good I know I
know David particularly yes that's
correct that's correct and they play
that recording by the way my older son
whom you know better also David the one
straight David at the table
but I said I there's one straight I
gotta say that it does if he cracks me
he cracks me up in General David but uh
he
he has he he has one complaint against
me you're gonna love this because if you
don't have a complaint against your
father you're not normal so he has one
complaint that I know of okay I can't
speak about others that I don't know of
dad you didn't push me hard enough in
school and he's right I didn't
I in fact I said I don't care if you do
your homework I care about your
character
very few parents say that but I'll tell
you something you get better character
all right Dennis now I'm going to ask
you the hardest question I can ask you
because you gave me the perfect segue
which is the thing that my mom often
says to me she says I know you've become
good friends with Dennis Prager and uh
you know I agree with Dennis Prager on a
lot of things but he always talks about
character how important character is but
he voted for Donald Trump he supports
Donald Trump
talk to my mother Dennis
I I have an answer to your mother Mom
God forbid you or a loved one has cancer
I got two oncologists for you one with
great character one with a compromised
character but who treats cancer better
which would you go to
you don't choose everybody on character
you choose a leader on what he will do
or she will do as the case may be for
your country whether they are kind or
monogamous or whatever that is between
them and their spouse and God between me
and them John F Kennedy had orgies in
the White House in my opinion
incidentally this is truly incidentally
I believe that Joe Biden's character is
so much more deficient than Donald Trump
they won't even end up in the same place
in the Hereafter they I'm not they won't
be neighbors nevertheless it doesn't
matter to me I don't vote for president
based on what I perceive as their
character America is more important to
me than whether Donald Trump slept with
a porn star that is of no interest to me
whatsoever it's of interest to me if my
son does it but I'm not voting for him
for president was that a hard one for
you to sell couple years back for your
audience that's known you for so long
and and talking about it Hey listen I
wrote a piece called adultery and
politicians 25 years ago it's in print
in my book of essays from 1998 called
think a second time adultery and
politicians I don't give a damn if a
politician was faithful or not to his
wife
so you've been pretty consistent on this
I've been very consistent that's right
all right so let's the only thing that
the only thing I didn't know since high
school I I don't mean I haven't I've
learned a ton but the only big thing I
didn't realize till Ronald Reagan that's
when I became a Republican
the truth of his great one sentence the
government is not the solution it's the
problem
that that is what in one sentence people
say how can you get so much done in five
minutes in a preview video it doesn't
take five minutes a truth can take one
sentence but government is the problem
not the solution he was entirely was it
Reagan also I learned President Reagan
also the worst eight words you can hear
in the English language I'm here from
the government or I'm from the
government and I'm here to help right I
mean
exactly correct that's pretty good
speaking of Prager you real quick little
sidebar you guys are about to put up
your 500th
five minute video I've done four of
those uh would you say they're the four
best
oh
there's no close third
I mean it's pretty amazing what you
built you know you and Alan you just had
or he I guess had the original idea sort
of I've heard you talk about a little
bit the original idea uh in the Indian
Ocean I'm my head
and you put this thing together and now
uh every day the New York Times is
running hit pieces on you
well you know my favorite you will love
this I don't know if you know this Front
Page New York Times last month
uh an attack on uh who was oh oh on Elon
Musk
and in the front Bay of the front page
it said he must be watching prageru
videos
I loved it yeah you don't know how you
don't have much fundraising
yeah I bet I bet yes exactly 500 videos
it's pretty impressive but wait I want
to Circle back so you want to go into
some of the other of the seven we I was
going to jump to some other things but I
feel like I feel like you can basically
interview yourself I don't think
I want to make something clear to to
your to your viewers
the most important thing in life is
wisdom good intentions don't mean crap
May mean nothing the amount of evil done
by people with good intentions is
greater than the amount of evil done by
sadists
so if you think you're good because you
have good intentions join the list of
people who know who haven't done any
good
you need wisdom to make a better world
and to lead and to make a better
character for yourself these five books
are wisdom about every aspect of life
and I I am I am so in love with the
Torah the first five books and and thank
God I know them in Hebrew because
obviously I don't think I could have
done this without knowing the Hebrew
I am so in love with it that you'll find
this you you who are making your way
gradually to a less secular life
I you'll find this of interest and I say
this now a lot in in uh
in speeches
I don't believe in the Torah because I
believe in God I believe in God because
I believe in the Torah
my vehicle to belief in God is rational
it's why my series is called the
rational Bible
this is the third of five of those books
my vehicle to God is Not Miracles is not
Visions is not emotion it is and I'm not
saying everyone's vehicle but mine is
reason
the Torah is my rational vehicle to God
and I make that case in each of these
volumes so I gave you example of the of
those two laws here's another one let's
see oh God you shall okay the Ten
Commandments is repeated in Deuteronomy
it God says it in Exodus and Moses
repeats it in Deuteronomy
and Deuteronomy means in Greek Second
Law so this is Moses reviewing
everything
so one of them is of course you shall
not have no other gods and I point that
in both Exodus and Deuteronomy we have
more Gods today than any ancient Pagan
had when you think of the false gods
that people believe in today and you
know and I go through them and it's like
just one example science I believe in
science and I go what the hell does that
mean the signs tell you to be kind the
science tell you to be honest the
science tell you to marry the signs tell
you to have children do science tell you
to be courageous science tells you
nothing but you can it tells tells you
you can also ask the science people they
believe in science then ask them if boys
can become girls and they get quiet real
quick
that's right that's exactly right
exactly right we this was science we it
was science not to have kids in school
Sweden had kids in school every single
day not one died that wasn't science
that was scared scientists who were
worthless and and harmful so do you
connect that there's a big difference
between scientists and science so do you
connect that to what we talked about
earlier that that in a weird way people
need to believe whether they believe
that or not so that whether they think
they have to or not they end up
believing in something thus the
secularists just or the progressives
whatever you want to call them they just
pick the different set of beliefs period
that that is exact yes exactly you know
Mother Earth I don't believe in Mother
Earth but I believe the Earth was
created by God for humans to use not
abuse but use okay humans are more
important than trees more important than
Apes that is my that is my
human-centered divinely given belief
that's just another example so which
which do you believe are the humans a
curse on Earth or or are the humans to
uh to to control Earth for the good of
the human species I believe the latter
by that yes do you sense that over the
last couple years because of the covid
craziness and the way our politics has
become you know cult-like or whatever
that people are waking up to something
more rational or maybe they're not
saying okay I'm ready to make that leap
of faith you had a certain set of people
but that there is something happening
you know it's like if you're going to
tell people that they're sons are their
daughters they might go you know maybe
some of that old stuff in the Torah or
some of those other old books is pretty
good
if they're exposed to it which is my
dream our 4 000 reviews by the way when
when Exodus came out it was the number
two book on Amazon which is astonishing
for a Bible commentary uh you know and
why didn't why do you write them in a
different order
I I be totally honest I wrote them in
the order
that I thought would appeal to people to
get them involved if I started with
Deuteronomy nobody would know what the
hell I was doing but everybody heard of
Exodus and everybody heard of Genesis so
I started with the two most widely known
books and I'm working my way through
maybe when I get to Leviticus if you ask
the average I believe this truly if you
went on Harvard campus and said to a kid
hey you did Jeff you know what Leviticus
is he would probably say no said well
Leviticus is is uh is the favorite horse
in the Kentucky Derby they go no kidding
they love Leviticus you know they'll
yeah Leviticus oh man Leviticus fan club
who win the Triple Crown
um wait I want to back up to us I've
jotted down a couple notes Here I
usually don't have to jot down notes for
an interview much less with a friend but
there's so much going on here that I I
actually did write a few things down
um and and you obviously you do this all
the time on your radio show and
everywhere else you talk about goodness
so much and you connect that really to
the Torah that it's not just knowledge
or wisdom as you would put it but
goodness is also baked in there and it
doesn't seem like we have a lot of that
right now
so my my underlying belief and that of
the Torah is that God wants people to be
good
that is why and it's one of the reasons
that I am in love with the Torah it
makes clear you don't have to be a Jew
for God to reward you
you could be a pagan you can be
obviously they didn't exist then but
later a Christian it could be anything
God judges your behavior not your
theology
and and that is one of the greatest
lessons it's called ethical monotheism
it is my fundamental belief
if one wants to become a Jew one is more
than welcome but the Jewish belief is
not that you have to be a Jew to be
saved you have to be a good person
nobody is perfect I said good not
perfect
God made us flawed and so we have to do
the best we can you want to do the best
you can you have to learn wisdom you
can't be a good person if you're a fool
it's that's that's the basic fundamental
understanding and in order to gain
wisdom you have to study wisdom that's
why I wrote a column a few weeks ago I
had more wisdom and so did all the kids
in my class at Yeshiva then then 90 of
today's college professors
again when I was 15
I had more wisdom and so did my other
Yeshiva classmates and so did Christian
kids in traditional Christian Schools
than than 90 of the professors in
America today we studied wisdom we
understood for example we knew that
people's nature was not basically good
and and the average Professor probably
thinks human nature is basically good
which is the beginning of foolishness
you can't have a coherent worldview if
you think human nature is essentially
good is that also why politics is is so
screwy that uh we have a bunch of people
who just want to take advantage of
people who are not wise I mean if you
just turn on you turn on almost anything
and it's like man you'd have to be
pretty pretty unwise to be buying any of
this nonsense from mainstream media
these days
yeah well but but it the point is it's
the unwise leading the otherwise it's
not like they're wise and they're
fooling the unwise
is Gavin Newsom a wise man my audience
knows my feelings it is Lori Lightfoot a
wise woman I mean but wisdom isn't
valued it isn't taught
that's that's the great that's why these
books that I'm writing I think are so
incredibly important look nobody writes
a Bible commentary to get rich
I'm writing it because this is my legacy
of my life's work people need to
understand the greatest five books ever
written and that's what this project is
called the rational Bible I should
mention that actually last time I saw
you was just a couple weeks ago with
with Jordan Peterson and you were in
town because you were doing uh correct
me his biblical series though so you
went through Exodus with him and yeah
and we're gonna well and we only got
through half and we're gonna do the
other half by the way you'll get a kick
out of this so it was he invited five of
us five or six of us and you know with
the daily wire it's a beautiful project
and I was delighted to be part of it he
wrote to be something to the effect I'm
really glad you were there we needed
somebody to make us laugh I realized I
realized he meant you I think he met you
I don't know if I should even bet I
think he meant you what that's what the
Jews are supposed to do
yeah I guess so it was it was very funny
I realized within the first hour uh oh
if I don't start saying some really
silly things we're doomed
when when you have these talks so I I
met I wasn't with you guys that night
but I was with with that whole crew the
biblical crew a night or two it later
when you're with all these people and
you're I think you were the only one
coming at it from a Jewish perspective
but then there were obviously Christians
and Catholics and all sorts of other
things do you find that there are really
places of Divergence that that can't be
sort of accommodated or that you can't
walk away and all be kind of okay it all
depends on it all depends on the
Christian I'm with I I mean for example
Oz Guinness whom I fell in love with he
was one of the others a guy he has
written about 30 books which is three
times more than I've written uh he
for all intention purposes he was like a
fellow Jew in terms of thought and
Theology of course he believes in Christ
he's a Christian
but
the uh
otherwise he was my Ally uh on every
point and most of them would be
there is Much More Much Greater
difference between a conservative and a
left-wing Jew than between a
conservative Jew and a Conservative
Christian or a liberal Jew and a liberal
Christian the Divergence today is right
left not Christian Jew yeah and that
Divergence doesn't seem to be uh going
anywhere from the political
scene no well no it's not just political
social philosophical moral we have
nothing in common left and right have
nothing in common I say this with
sadness but I live in the real world so
how do we get out of here how do we get
out of that I mean I'm the only way to
get out of it is well it's not the only
way the best way or or one of the key
ways is is disseminate what we stand for
which is why this Prager you which is
why I'm writing the rational Bible which
is why you do what you do
uh
that is why by the way they try to shut
us down they know we can undo why is it
a big deal if you go to a college campus
or I do or or Ben Shapiro or Jordan
Peterson or Candace Owens why did they
give a damn
they have four years to indoctrinate we
get a 90 minutes because they know in
their heart we can undo four years and
90 minutes that's good sometimes we can
undo four years in five minutes that's
that's even better that's right hence
the preview videos that's right that's
even better uh let's dive into a couple
of the other uh pieces here
um chapter 13 is why would God test us
this is obviously one that you've been
asked in a million Forums on every
probably radio show you've ever done uh
why would God shouldn't things just be a
little bit easier come on there's God
he's moral we're trying to be good
couldn't he just take it easy on us just
a little bit why do bad things happen to
good people Dennis
well that's those are two separate
questions bad things happening to good
people and testing us I don't regard all
suffering as a Divine test because it
would imply that if your kid has cancer
God gave your kid cancer and I don't
believe that for a second
God created a world where bad things can
happen
and uh my best answer to this question
which is I've been absorbed with all of
my life since high school
I heard a statement from a rabbi Milton
Steinberg
and he from I think he said it I I
didn't hear it from directly I read it
I love it he said the following
the believer in God has to explain one
thing
the the existence of unjust suffering
the atheist
has to explain the existence of
everything else
I find that the best answer I've ever
heard to this problem I don't deny it's
a problem
unjust suffering I don't deny it
but compared to what the atheist has to
explain
literally everything else and for which
he has no explanation
then uh I'm back to belief in God with
my question
that's what they always say
we're in a Multiverse anything's
possible
you're right the only thing that's not
possible is a Multiverse
that must be what believing in one God
is all about it just kind of keeps you
off the Multiverse
listen just remember this
and this this should be a message even
to people like you and it is I know
because you're now thinking that maybe
religion has something important to say
there were very few outliers
during the covet Hysteria
and almost all of them were religious
Christian or Jew
that that's not insignificant
if a place was going to be open
and and most by the way most synagogues
and churches I I think failed the test
terribly they they succumbed to secular
irrational Authority just like everybody
else but those institutions that didn't
were almost all religious
it's like who's it's like who rescued
Jews in the Holocaust very few people
but among them overwhelmingly they were
religious people
most religious people fail the test
but of those who passed the test most
were religious
that's basically as a high of kind of
credit as you can give to religion I
suppose when when yeah
not every religious person is terrific
but most terrific people are religious
chapter 34 I thought this was really
interesting in light of politics and
something we kind of discussed earlier
people in positions of authority should
not seek to be loved this is on page 508
it's a hefty book
um it seems like almost everybody in
politics is there to be loved they do
seem to love the Limelight I would say
not all I would say we have an exception
here in Florida of a guy that's trying
to just do the good job that he's put
that's right yeah right but most of them
so let me this is you I'm so happy you
picked on that
the single greatest crisis has been the
parental Authority crisis since World
War II
parents decided that the thing they
wanted most was that their kids loved
them and that ended Parenthood and ended
our societies
growth as a moral Society building good
people
the moment the parent wants to be loved
that is the end of their parenting the
moment a political leader wishes to be
loved that is the end of their validity
as a political leader the moment the
teacher wants to be loved that is the
end of their teaching ability the only
people we should want to be loved from
are our spouses and Friends end of issue
um well I know somebody is watching this
thinking but wait a minute Dennis I I
can accept what you said on Trump
related to the uh you know whether he
had sex with other women or whatever but
he does seem like he wants to be loved
Trump yeah
if there's one thing even his enemies
have to uh he loves to be loved by his
followers but uh as a general rule
Trump has disdained he oh that's
interesting
you're making a distinction between sort
of someone who has let's say followers
or supporters that love them versus he's
not going for institutional love or
something I mean that's kind of
whittling it down but you think yes or
or exactly no no Abby
Trump trump you could say Trump loves
Trump
but that Trump does what he does for
love
given this the swiftness with which he
he will okay lash out at people he he's
the last person I would accuse of doing
what he does for love
I got it I got it
um yeah but love comes along the way
when you do this isn't that something
isn't that something when you do
something that's good and honest and
true you get a lot of love I mean I've
been out and about with you well that is
right that's the irony isn't it
if you act nobly and not in pursuit of
love you will end up with a lot of love
that is so you know one of the most
common things people say to me at
airports and restaurants
say oh you know I just want you know I
love you but ah I'm sure you hear it all
the time so I go well I hear it all the
time but on the other hand I'd like you
to just Google Dennis Prager [ __ ] and
see how many hits you get
there's worse things you could Google
about either one of us I'm sure you know
that actually that is correct that
actually reminds me of something that I
hope you don't mind me bringing this up
when when Jordan and I and you had
dinner a couple weeks ago and I was
fortunate enough I don't know how many
people would trade almost everything
they got to right before they're about
to be a father to sit down with Dennis
Prager and Jordan Peterson and one
interesting thing that we noticed
between the three of us is that if you
don't mind me saying you are 74 years
old Jordan is 60 and I'm 46 so we have
14 years between the three of us which
was just sort of oh that's yeah it was
just sort of interesting to think about
but you said something when we were
talking about how to how to parent and
teach the children the right thing and
all this you said um something to the
effect of how uh that whatever your your
parents faults were whatever you might
look back and fault them for that you
said but I turned out to be a good moral
person so I can let all of those things
go I'm roughly paraphrasing right but I
thought it was a I thought it was a
really decent way of moving forward in
life because everyone's got issues with
their parents but a lot of people are
just focused on them all day long
which is why by the way another
Brilliance of the Torah
were instructed to honor our parents but
not to love them
and we are told to love the stranger to
love God to love our neighbor but we're
not told to love our parents
realizes in its genius
that cannot be demanded of people it can
be demanded of people that they not
dishonor their parents uh this is why
I'm I tell you this is reason number
eight five six six why I'm in love with
the Torah how do you square that with
people who just have you know just
generally terrible parents I mean
alcoholic abusive neglectful Etc et
cetera that's right so
I I spoke about that on my Rosh Hashanah
service
as a general rule exceptions there's a
rule in law what is it bad cases make
bad law
nothing can cover every instance do we
all acknowledge that we should stop at
red lights yes
How about if the guy next to you in the
car your passenger has a heart attack
and you it's a matter of time that you
have to get him to a hospital
will you go through a red light if you
can yes will everybody justify it yes so
we all understand there are exceptions
to rules but it takes a lot and you just
have to answer to God for this it takes
a lot
to justify not honoring a parent and
I'll give an example
you are not justified if your parent
voted for Trump and you hate Trump
you're a scumbag if you don't talk to
your father or mother because they voted
for Trump you're just a lousy damn
narcissistic kid
Unworthy of anything positive to be said
about you and I would say that to a
conservative kid who didn't vote for a
parent who voted for Biden but there
doesn't exist such a kid because if we
conservatives met a guy oh I don't talk
to my father he voted for Biden we tell
are you an a-hole but that was that
after there was your father your schmuck
I I do think about that a lot where it's
like you know if if uh I I had a chat
with Bill Maher on his podcast uh a
two-hour chat and I wanted to bring up
what happened with you and him from a
couple months back on his show where you
basically said you know Google women or
Google men menstruating and he kind of
brushed it off but it's true now that is
sort of a main point of the left right
now men can menstruate okay I didn't
unfortunately it didn't come up uh but I
had a chat with him uh and one of the
things that we were sort of dancing
around that I was trying to explain to
him in some ways was that if someone
that's conservative leaning walks into a
room full of liberals you're going to be
berated or ignored or treated horribly
or sneered at or something if a liberal
or a lefty whatever you want to call it
at this point walks into a room of
conservatives mostly they'll be super
friendly and then maybe they'll turn
around and be like boy that guy's an
idiot but but it'll sort of be like
it'll be like sort of a joke my whole
life is an example of that exactly
go no no what what is an example well my
life in a way that I was I was in both
those circles I know how they both
operate and when when you meet if you're
hanging out with the European beers or
whatever different drinks whatever
smoking cigars as you would with a bunch
of conservatives and a liberal walks in
everyone's curious about why they think
that way but the other way it's like why
are you a Nazi
that's right yeah that's right I have
nothing to add to it that is exactly
correct it turns out we're nicer than
they are that's the irony but I thought
we're so scary Dennis
I know well well we're scary with them
for for some reason you know who gave
the reason in part
the prime the new prime minister of it
wasn't that incredible what a speech
those two minutes summarized everything
and but I will just say I wrote this 20
years ago
but it doesn't matter to hear it from an
Italian Prime Minister it gives me such
Joy
when she said they hate the fact that we
have an identity yes I am a woman I am a
Christian I am an Italian
and that I'm a mother
it was so great I said this about George
Soros a long time ago George Soros has
no identity he has no national identity
and he has no religious identity and the
people with no identity hate the people
who have one and that that really almost
sums up you said everything you know
it's left for his right but really that
almost is it it's the it's the people of
the Borg of the collective identity
versus the people who it's a little
messy because you're not going to
believe that they're going to think
about things a little bit differently
right well are you are you hopeful are
you hopeful for the country and for the
world because when I when I hang with
you you're laughing you laugh more than
anyone I know you've got such a
boisterous laugh you're always having a
great time I see you with when fans come
up to you I mean you're always having a
ball but but this is you know it's not
guaranteed that this thing's gonna get
us to the other side and people are
gonna be better and think better and be
more wise
I have figured out how to have a bowl
as the building falls down
I'm not saying I'm not saying it will
fall down but there are massive cracks
in the edifice
I am not philosophically an optimist I
don't know how any Jew could be given
the amount of suffering given the fact
that
the most
advanced Society culturally in the world
Germany
the place of Beethoven and and Bach and
and uh and uh and Schiller and geta
produces Auschwitz nobody expected it
nobody expected it
so I I'm not a big optimist
but it I don't give a damn about
optimism or pessimism I only give a damn
about what do I have to do
and if they died on Normandy Beach at 20
years of age for Liberty in America I
could live for Liberty America and that
that's what I do and in the meantime I
have a great time
I love being at your house
well speaking of being at my house we
can we can end with this then
um when I left Florida when I left
California you were at my table for the
last meal the Last Supper in California
when I begged you and Larry Elder and a
couple people to come I had you on my
show a couple months ago I reiterated
the point I had you for dinner here a
couple weeks ago Sue was here people
have been here what are you doing what
are you doing at this point it's it's
insulting
I tell everybody
Dave Rubin sends my wife and me every
damn week another great house on sale in
his neighborhood I'm on Zillow half the
day just sending let me just tell you it
it does have an effect
we're not moving yet but I need to tell
you we we scour that house we read
everything about it then it's all I'm
saying all I'm saying is your house
across the street from me for sale
directly imagine you could wake up in
the morning cup of coffee I come over we
chat about philosophy there's a tennis
court Dennis a tennis court
oh God I know
uh the problem as you know is the number
of people I love who are here including
I founded a synagogue here which is very
meaningful to me every every Sabbath and
then I do my high holy days
uh so um it's a tear uh I totally get
why you moved I totally get it
Dennis I anyway I really I really hope
your people will get the rational Bible
the new volume I I I promised them it'll
change their life I promise
it's very powerful stuff well look
you've you've changed my life personally
and professionally I mentioned to you at
my Passover seder this past year we had
the rational hagata where you can go
through the story of Passover and get
wisdom not only from you but Jordan
Peterson and some other people in our
circles I found it uh it's a little more
I would say edible than uh maybe the old
uh Maxwell House agada it started to age
on me a little you know well it's
certainly richer there's a coffee joke
there somewhere Dennis I love you I hope
to see you soon
it's mutual same here if you're looking
for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about spirituality instead
of non-stop yelling check out our
spirituality playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics check out our full episode
playlist they're all right over here and
to get notified of all future videos be
sure to subscribe and click the
notification Bell